sexual harassment isn't what it used to
be feeling lost confused attacked
stay tuned for answers on how to stay
afloat in this changing tide hello I'm
Paula Anderson and I'm Natalie Van algol
now we're here to congratulate you
because if you're watching this that
means you're a very successful man but
times have changed and you can't treat
women the way you have for the past
twenty thirty forty forever years
thankfully we as [__] you stop it can
help with the advanced technology of our
workplace simulator we will prepare you
for any scenario the job might throw
your way we help high-powered executives
are you ready for your simulation mr.
Jenkins oh absolutely
although I got to warn you some of the
people that work for me say that I'm a
pretty evolved boss they call me awoke
it's just look what Natalie here will be
playing your coworker let's start hello
mr. Jenkins hello Natalie so I'm gonna
go ahead and grab that file for you and
I will call the head office
great work Natalie then I'll go ahead
and file my head into your office oh I
was just gonna explain that of course by
office I meant lady cave and bifi oh I D
file why would you say that because I
want to have sex with her and I wanted
to be super clear just because you're
horny doesn't mean you have sex with
your employees
got it I am sorry mmm what's happening
well I was just going to kiss you
so I say I'm sorry I French kiss I think
you're missing the point
Hollywood elite so Brad asked nerd
director of black cop white cop one and
for now we're gonna run through a
scenario yeah let's I'm excited to learn
okay I wasn't done Paula your assistant
is going to come in and drop off the
script good to see you yeah that that's
actually something I'm pretty
comfortable with because I get a lot of
scripts I work in Hollywood riveting
offset right this is the nearest draft
of the script I'm putting it on your
desk and I'm going to walk out okay
great actually before you leave I'm
gonna throw on some filthy pornography
and I'm gonna take my pants off and
watch it maybe you take your pants off
too and we'll just watch it together
what I'm gonna put on raunchy porno and
maybe we watch at pantless oh that was
good though that felt good it didn't so
Paula came in and then you wanted her to
watch porn panelist yeah well I've my
pants off too but like I said I'd pay
her if she was gonna be the worst about
it or whatever angle is but I work for
you
so you guys know that I directed black
cop wake up one for guys guys I think
we've definitely learned that even the
creative arts are not immune to this
sort of thing watching porn with a
co-worker is a real negotiation now how
about we bury the hatchet with a round
of sorry kisses no why are you still
here very specifically told you to leave
yeah mate no sorry you had to see that
no I didn't know we're not taking turns
Brett I'm a big fan
thank you thanks for watching you guys
are the best
that's a good dude we help people in
government
senator Wentworth Natalie here will be
interviewing for your staffing position
that sounds delightful
let's begin Oh where did you go to
college I went to Sarah Lawrence hmm the
Oh female institution yes I have this
enormous shower in the back why don't we
get some of your classmates in here Oh
get all soapy and then have ok I am an
important man it doesn't matter
it used to there was a time in this
country where a giant shower in the back
of a senator's office was a license to
have a Sarah Lawrence orgy but senator
I'm afraid those days are done it's true
what sweet sweet Paula here and
what's-her-face have taught me today is
that you certainly can't take a shower
with interviewees without their consent
so what do you say do I have your
consent
[Music]
all right well I'll be in the shower
later
I'm already naked
[Music]
Judith
hey listen I'm all boned up on eight
hours of appropriateness training what
are you doing right now
you there
you